now that Spiderman has come to the MCU
long time Marvel fans can rest easy the
new spider-man is a hit and we're sure
to see more of Tom Holland and the red
and blue webs in the years to come but
while everyone knows about the
importance of Peter Parker aren't May
and Adrian Toomes there are a lot of
other characters hanging out in this
movie who may prove to be much more
important than you might have suspected
strap in nerds and let's chat about the
characters from spider-man homecoming
with more meaning than you realized
oh and do you feel that tingling my
spider sensors are starting to tingle
that's your spidey sense warning you
about the Spidey spoilers about to fly
at your eyeballs Michelle the ending
reveal of Michelle's true identity that
she's MJ to her friends points to the
coming importance for the character in
Peter Parker's life as fans of both the
comics and the movies no a pizza and
MJ's stories have been intertwined for
years she's first mentioned the way way
back in 1964 amazing spider-man issue 15
but it took two years before fans and
pizza finally got a look at her face
which first showed up an amazing
spider-man issue 42 in 1966 as the years
went on MJ became Peters on-again
off-again girlfriend in the 80s she took
their relationship to the next level
when she revealed that she figured out
his secret identity in amazing
spider-man issue 257 meanwhile there
were more than a few hints in homecoming
that indicated MJ has feelings for Peter
and the may even though his secret hey
hi what are you hiding Peter eventually
Peter and Mary Jane married in 1987
amazing spider-man annual number 21 21
years later Peter literally sold his
marriage to Mary Jane to the devil to
keep his oldest decrepit Aunt May from
croaking after she was shot by bad guys
needless to say this new MJ has a lot of
weird times to look forward to Ned Ned
leaves in the comics doesn't much
resemble the ned we got in homecoming
leads started out as a Daily Bugle
reporter in the 1960s and soon became a
romantic rival for pizza both of the
guys are interested in the same girl
Betty Brant and eventually Peter backed
off while Ned and Betty wound up getting
married
the union was not meant to last because
the villain known as Hobgoblin
brainwashed Annette into becoming
another Hobgoblin also he could have a
full guy to take the blame if the cops
got too close eventually leaves would
get pathetically murdered in a hotel
room or dressed up as Hobgoblin or dead
Ned but that's not all
many fans have pointed out that the net
we get in the movie bears a strong
resemblance to gong Cayley the best
friend of ultimate spider-man Miles
Morales it's not entirely clear why the
movies producers decided to smoosh these
two characters together into one but if
he turns out to have more in common with
his namesake than his look-alike our
friend Ned better watch out for
brainwashing machines
seriously Aaron Davis on the subject of
ultimate versions of characters donald
glover plays aaron davis who gets mixed
up with Adrian Toomes and his gang of
super weapons salvages in the comics
that name belongs to the prowler who
happens to also be the uncle of Miles
Morales in fact it's because of prowlers
extra legal shenanigans Myles gets his
spidery Palace in homecoming Davis hears
about climbing gear on offer from the
vultures gang and also mentions later
that he's got a nephew in the city he
cares about so don't be surprised to see
Davis make a comeback in a sequel right
along with the movie version of fan
favorite Miles Morales Mac Gargan why
demands had a lot of villains over the
years and a few have been as persistent
as Mac Gargan originally Mac assumed the
identity of the costume department
scorpion fun fact the Scorpion was a
result of Mad Science gone wrong all
bankrolled by the Daily Bugle publisher
Jay jonah Jameson because Mark got stuck
in the scorpion suit he's long held a
grudge against Jameson as well as
spider-man years later he bonded with
the alien symbiote the one that tried to
eat Peter Parker back in the 80s to
become the new venom the partnership
didn't last too long though and
eventually Olmec went back to being the
scorpion considering he put in an
appearance during the ferry scene and
during the mid-credits scene in the
prison not to mention his scorpion
tattoo chances seemed good that he'll be
back with a much larger role to play in
a spider sequel shocker in homecoming we
get not one but two incarnations of
classic Spidey villain
the first one bites the big one when he
crosses the vulture so Herman Schultz
takes on the vibro knuckles to become
the second shocker
comic fans know that Herman shelters the
shockers real name from the comics but
while he's a mainstay of spider-man's
rogues gallery shock has never really
been an a-list villain that's just kind
of what happens when your costume
consists of a brown v-neck that goes
down to your crotch and the yellow quilt
on your face the tinkerer Adrian Toomes
is mechanically inclined hence Gaius
Phineas Mason better known in the comics
faithful in this alter-ego the tinkerer
okay as far as intimidating supervillain
names go the tinkerer isn't that good
but it's still better than paste-pot
pete rice and stilt man everyone's
better than still man the tinkerer first
appeared all the way back in 1963 the
amazing spider-man issue - which also
happened to be the first appearance of
the vulture since that time he's hung
around in the background of the Marvel
Universe
inventing gadgets and upgrading devices
- plenty of bad guys that includes dudes
like a big wheel the Grizzly and the
Apple mentioned uilt man forget
seriously you can never have too much
still man thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you're not saying
[Applause]
you